[Musica]
alla quante volte nella vita ci capita
di essere vittima di stereotipi cioè
sicuramente capita a noi è capitato
magari scherzosamente a volte più
drammatico a volte addirittura tragico
però sono sicuro che anche tutti quelli
che sono qui in sala con noi lo hanno
vissuto almeno una volta
noi siamo ragazzi del sud forse non si
sente però siamo del sud ve lo diciamo
subito e siamo qui per dirvi che non
bisogna cancellare gli stereotipi non
bisogna cancellarli lo sappiamo che
detta così sembra un po strana perché lo
dice ma come gli stereotipi sono
negativi vanno cancellati e la facciamo
un gioco
immaginiamo che questa scatola sia uno
stereotipo cosa vediamo dello stereotipo
la superficie nel caso della scatola
qualcosa di marrone ruvido insomma
vediamo questo ma che succede se
scaviamo dentro uno stereotipo che
succede se lo apriamo e vediamo cosa c'è
dentro
negli ultimi anni noi abbiamo fatto
questo abbiamo preso degli stereotipi
che sono vicini a noi abbiamo provato a
guardare cosa c'è dentro e quello che
abbiamo scoperto è che ci sono valori
identità caratteristiche di una
popolazione perché la vera domanda al di
uno stereotipo e dire perché esiste uno
stereotipo uno stereotipo esiste perché
tu che ne sei vittime altri dieci cento
mille a volte milioni di persone
condividete qualcosa e chiaro che nello
stereotipo questa cosa è negativa ma se
la trasforma in qualcosa di positivo
e probabile che la condivisione la
connessione tra te e tutte quelle
persone possa diventare una risorsa per
questo motivo abbiamo portato tre
stereotipi molto vicini a noi
appartenente alla nostra realtà e ve li
vorremmo raccontare ecco il primo
quindi se volete spostare un voto non
dove la critica presto e bene signora
domenica la bottiglia non dove si
domanda papa ma non dove vive cosa ci
scriva a farlo
buongiorno signora riguardino certo
punto mi ero accorto di essere ritardo
avevo pensato di portare le paste però
supportiamo le basi e poi alla fine
facevo tardi vi diamo è stato meglio se
neri stando a guardare le passo può
essere ma non proporre i tipi di martini
sono arrivati in orario non portò per
niente non mi portando il past masters
che redazione
[Musica]
scusate ma cosa ha fatto di male hanno
capito dice tutti quanti non dovevi non
dovete alla fine se non dovevo perché ci
rimane male modi ma non dovevi sti c per
dire cortesia dove perché ti attacca
alla grande non dovevi ma dove rimane
perché mi fermo che figurano non piace
ma dovevo o non dovevo non dovevi ma
dove non è successo
devo imparare o non devo entrare
dov'è allora noi siamo del sud quindi
non potevamo non iniziare con
l'argomento cibo anche perché lo
stereotipo che ci ha accompagnato in
questi anni ma non hanno lavorato i
propri anni di vita è stato al sud
mangiano sempre a sud pensano solo a
mangiare assunto ogni occasione è buona
per mangiare no non fate niente se non
si mangia andate agli eventi solo se si
mangia
c'è persino chi dice noi mangiamo per
vivere voi vivete per mangiare cioè voi
vivete per mangiare è vero noi viviamo
per mangiare ma se ci piace perché
dobbiamo negarlo è proprio lei che ci
piace poco
ci piace veramente assai cioè noi
mangiamo quando ci hanno invitato
altezza la prima cosa è bellissima si
mangia voci ha detto sì allora saliamo
siamo contenti siamo felici prima stavo
fuori stavo stavo di testa sul
telefonino è voluto uno degli
organizzatori e mi ha detto dagli states
ho detto sì in effetti un po costò teso
sappiamo non ti preoccupare ripeti la
parte che va tutto bene ma quale parte
sta ripetendo la parte il nostro vedendo
domandare a mangiare stasera perché sono
le sei e ancora non lo so se non è colpa
nostra
però giustamente al sud mangiano sempre
un po la superficie di questo cartone di
questa scatola no entriamo all'interno
di questa di questo stereotipo vediamo
cosa c'è dietro al termine al sud
manciano sempre prendiamo il cibo
prendiamo la tavola e iniziamo ad
inserire delle persone intorno a questa
tavola
le persone sono la famiglia che sfrutta
quell'occasione del mangiare per
ritrovarsi per condividere condividere
delle cose confrontarsi diciamo passare
dei momenti insieme ci sono degli amici
che dopo tanto tempo si ritrovano e
quindi hanno l'opportunità di confidarsi
ci sono persone che ritornano a casa
dopo mesi che stanno fuori per motivi di
studio o di lavoro e quindi è
l'occasione di stare a tavola insieme
alla famiglia insieme ai nonni insieme
parente e tutto il resto
intorno a quella tavola ci sono le
tradizioni perché il cibo è pure
tradizione il cibo è cultura
il cibo anche l'identità di un
territorio quello che proviamo a
raccontare noi
faccio un esempio pratico no arriva la
mamma che porta un piatto pieno di
peperone imbuto nate no i peperoni
ripieni che c'è dietro quel piatto no
dietro quel patto quel piatto ci sta il
nonno che la coltivato ci sta e la
raccolto quindi l'amore di un nonno che
per produrlo ci sta una mamma che ci ha
lavorato quasi diciamo tutta la
mattinata per cucinarlo e condividerlo
lì a tavola giustamente voi dite ma però
ci vogliono dieci minuti per mangiarlo
ma qual è il problema sud non è il tempo
per mangiarli estendo per digerirli
farlo serio e perone stiamo a tavola
tanto tempo no perché mangiamo noi
digeriamo a tavola c'è quello è il
passaggio lupo di robo caro tutta lo
mangi o ti alzi e te ne vai
provate ad alzarvi dopo che vi siete
mangiare un peperone un botton ato che
ha fatto vostra nonna
l'effetto è tipo quando ti sparano con
il sonnifero gli animali tu lo mangi è
buono
dopo un po che inizia quindi l'effetto
ci prova ad alzarmi ma dopo due metri ma
cascio
no perché giustamente entra l'effetto
però non butto nata e ancora non so qual
è l'ingrediente segreto che ci mette la
nonna però questo per dire però quel
momento lì è importante dove tu con dvd
delle cose giuste rendono pur dire
immaginate se invece questo stereotipo
noi avessimo cancellato viene meno il
cibo viene meno la tavola vengono meno
le persone
quindi tutto quello che vi ho raccontato
voi potete dire ok ma la tavola è
l'unico posto dove voi potete
condividere queste cose
no però provate a convincerci che esista
un posto migliore della tavola dove
poterlo fare ora passiamo a secondo sta
già tipo sono contento che siete venuti
tutti perché mi devo fare un annuncio
molto molto importante e ormai lo sapete
ho cresciuto e quindi ho deciso di
andare a lavorare ma soprattutto deciso
di area nord
no
ecco è questa è la notizia un deciso di
lavorare al sud perché voglio
valorizzare la mia terra sarà superiore
che mi ha fatto poi riflettere capito
[Musica]
perché fatto vergogna non si può fare
niente questa kasper ha come fai fai
spagna il nord e il sud
grazie a questo nostro erotico a cui
teniamo molto perché noi veniamo dal sud
spesso si dice chi vive al sud deve
andare a lavorare al nord o addirittura
chi vive al sud non ha voglia di
lavorare e noi non vogliamo fare
polemica su questo stereotipo vogliamo
solamente raccontarvi una storia che
quella di casa surace che è nata cinque
anni fa ormai da un gruppo di amici come
tante volte succede che per entusiasmo
fanno una cosa improvvisamente quella
cosa va bene quando ha cominciato avere
successo la nostra attività
se avesse chiesto a chiunque intorno a
noi ma adesso che faranno questi ragazzi
io credo che chiunque avrebbe immaginato
la classica storia la classica favola
saliranno a milano dove ci sono le
agenzie c'è il marketing e poi chissà
magari arriveranno in europa
poi magari in america a new york
l'esame entrati in un auto abbiamo preso
la salerno reggio calabria e siamo scesi
giù al sud fino a sala consilina
probabilmente molti di voi non sanno
dove sala consilina questo non è uno
stereotipo un problema del posto diciamo
che è un piccolo nella cittadina di
quindicimila abitanti
però se qualcuno ci chiedesse ma perché
siete scesi
al sud non si tenda a di verso il nord
la nostra risposta sarebbe perché in
quel paesino per quanto era piccolo
c'erano tutti i valori che volevamo
raccontare
e se è vero che noi non critichiamo
ovviamente milano c'è assolutamente a
partecipare come città ma in generale è
chiaro che c'è chi può trovare lì la
propria identità ma noi probabilmente a
spostarci un altro posto seguendo quello
che è lo stereotipo che l'idea l'idea
generale di come fare le cose avremmo
perso i valori che invece abbiamo
trovato in un piccolo paesino sala
consilina è diventata per noi presenti 1
studios qualsiasi macellaio
fruttivendolo venditore panetti la sala
c'è un'idea su casa surace sa come sarà
il prossimo video c'è un consiglio è
fatto così ma lo puoi fare meglio
una volta dobbiamo giungere in
autostrada ci hanno chiuso in autostrada
e non sto scherzando
ma la cosa bella è che ce l'hanno chiusa
e come siamo andati dal vg abbia detto
mica dovremmo chiudere autostrada ok ha
preso una trentina ecco qua è chiuso e
non è finita lì perché ne abbia detto
quando ci serve dalle 9 alle 14
l'ha detto ma facciamo fine 21 per
sicurezza non si sa mai mette vedete fa
qualcosa in più ne abbiamo l'unico
scenografo di scenografia commestibile
perché presente se facciamo una
parmigiana qualsiasi cosa diciamo beppe
guarda che si può fare con la vernice
abbiamo visto un video bellissimo
americano lo fanno col vinavil ma bensì
con mangia dice beppe c'è dopo non si
può mangiare scusate traduco per l'altra
parte del nord e questi valori queste
risorse non le avremmo trovato da
nessun'altra parte perché quello è un
popolo che sa che riconosceva meta di
casa sorace di sala consilina
riconosceva se stesso nei video quindi
non erano professionisti che ovviamente
servono erano parenti parenti che ti
volevano aiutare come se andassi da una
zia da una madre dice si guarda mi serve
aiuto è il loro stesso atteggiamento
e a questo punto arriviamo all'ultimo
stereotipo che vogliamo far vedere che
appartiene a una figura a cui noi
teniamo veramente molto
richiamato il suo stesso nome esempio
the andrea invece semplice a questo
quando mi domandate qual è un evento
preferito
andrea risponde un appello a tutte le
volte che studiano ma perché quando non
avete studiato e dite sempre che è morta
la nonna
insomma si sono già 4 ogni tanto che
nonno ma voglio dire una cosa
ieri sono passato dando un bar e ho
visto che i gelate vanno da 85 centesimi
a 2 euro
forse perché ci fatto il resto da 50
euro che vi do ceu girato il 50 euro
pareva jan euro caramelle vanno al euro
girati 50 in meno elevate messa faccio
la festa ma non soffre a tutte le nonne
ma perché dite sempre le vostre reboot e
disoccupati per difendere foto il gorgo
e voi di casa sciupato come sciupate
pesa 90 kg 90 crisci parte basta questa
storia delle caramelle non è caduto il
nome dalle caramelle da abu dhabi che a
volte carabella il double bubble sami ed
è sempre inutile stannah provato una
lametta
[Musica]
dove volete stanno qua è che fossero le
foto che chiede la caramella comune di
sicuro ci fai
per me viene prima la caramella e pop in
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora l'ultimo stadio tipo è
stai sciupato no è un termine che ormai
tutte le nonne ti assillano striscio
pathos e sciupato devi mangiare ma
perché non mangi non ti vengo a trovare
a buono preparo da mangiare non maggior
mangiate da ben rimangi non fa mai male
mangi mangi ti mangi sciupato che ci
sarebbe detto così effettivamente è un
osservato con negativo cioè detta così è
un essere che andrebbe completamente
cancellato questa volta però non
vogliamo entrare all'interno di questo
stereotipo e vedere cosa c'è ma facciamo
un'altra cosa prendiamo lo stereotipo e
lo capovolgiamo vediamo cosa accade se
per una nonna da un momento all'altro
tutti gli abitanti del pianeta
diventassero sui nipoti francini numero
uno
dovete lavare le mani è che una novità
quante volte ve l'ho detto io si è
lavato le mani
no perché c'è il coronavirus per sempre
ed è lavata le mani che andavano avanti
ii consiglio quando starnutite dovete
starnutire e nel debito non è
coronavirus educazione con le volte che
ho detto metto la mano davanti e move e
dico metti il gomito davanti come tu
ginocchio ebete voci davano un pizzico
perché potete fare a chi poi lo grafico
verso consiglio per un poco di tempo
dobbiamo evitare baci e abbracci perché
hanno detto è pericoloso potremmo fare
quando ci vediamo
invece dei baci e abbracci massimo
luccioli chiararia elogi copriamo era
mangiata bella nonna come stai su pato
che mi piace facciamo così una cosa
importante non discriminiamo l'etnia per
il coronavirus noi che siamo abituati a
essere discriminati vogliamo essere noi
a discriminare voi russe colpa dei
cinesi nata cosa il colpa dell'africa
ricordate che il coronavirus passa la
discriminazione resta giusto vaccini ma
messi che scatenò anche forse siete noi
non andate in panico preferiscono le
scorte nei supermercati ci siamo noi e
allora andiamo un po con raggiunto da
noi mi siete tutti i parenti
due sere fa hanno fatto siete all'ordine
ecco mi hanno fatto ticinese scherzetto
a quasi cinese perché due parti una età
adesso vi saluto come un grande
abbraccio
[Musica]
allora nonna rosetta a 87 anni è nata
non vorrebbe che lo diciamo da beta non
c'è è nata a san giorgio a cremano e
vive a sala consilina
era una signora di 87 anni ferma davanti
alla televisione prima che la kia
massimo per fare un video e poi ha avuto
questa accesa e la tenda l'attrice più
dato è l'attrice più odiata da tutti gli
attori che hanno fatto una carriera non
in un anno ormai è e anche diciamo il
segreto per dire che non c'è un'età per
cominciare perché l'evento 87 anni
aspettava che andasse così
ma quello che vogliamo dire come una
nonna di un piccolo paese di 15.000
persone arriva a parlare a tutto il
mondo
diamo i numeri di questo video non per
vanità ma veramente per far capire cosa
è successo questo ovviamente era la
prima ondata di di pandemia c'era
confusione noi volevamo fare un video
per raccontare come affrontare e
l'abbiamo fatto veramente in semplicità
e il video fatto circa 400 milioni di
visualizzazioni in tutto il mondo è
stato tradotto in brasiliano in
portoghese in cinese in giapponese
perché perché in realtà tutti in quel
momento in particolare ma in generale
avevano bisogno di qualcuno che si
prendesse cura di loro e la nonna
proprio come figura è probabilmente la
figura che più di qualunque altra si è
presa cura di te in quel momento ne
abbiamo capito che potevamo aiutare
tutti l'abbiamo capito quando da tutto
il mondo ci sono arrivati messaggi di
ringraziamento da chi non aveva una
nonna da chi non aveva una figura di
riferimento o anche da chi l'aveva
perché in qualche modo si sentivano
tranquillizzati da quella figura
perciò torniamo al concetto da cui
abbiamo iniziato non ha potuto parlare a
tutti perché erano dei valori così
universali che non importa dove nascono
ma l'importante è che arrivino a quei
valori nei paradossalmente li abbiamo
trovati in uno stereotipo siamo partiti
da uno scherzo siamo partiti dal fatto
che la nonna ti dice sempre stai
sciupato e siamo arrivati a parlare a
tutto il mondo per questo motivo vi
ripetiamo un'ultima volta che non
bisogna cancellare gli stereotipi ma
bisogna guardarci dentro e per chiudere
siccome non tutti proprio gli stereotipi
vanno cancellati
lo sappiamo che noi questa scatola che
voi questa scatola l'avete vista come
una metafora
immaginate che vota
noi la chiamiamo pacco da judy solito
invece per invitarvi a guardare dentro
gli stereotipi cui ci sono sfogliatelle
che vengono direttamente dal nostro sud
quindi se volete per noi favorite
[Applauso]